يتحدث عن حقيقة أنه على المدى المتوسط
سوف تنشأ مشاكل في روسيا في المستقبل
نعم، هذه هي المنافذ التي تم إخلاؤها بسبب
رحيل بعض الأوروبيين و
بدأ الأمريكيون في الاحتلال
الشركات المحلية الوضع مشابه
لتلك التي تشكلت قبل 8 سنوات
سوق المواد الغذائية لدينا عندما تكون في
ورداً على العقوبات، قدمنا ​​عقوباتنا الخاصة
ثم بدأت الإجراءات التقييدية
النمو السريع للمجمع الصناعي الزراعي
الآن هناك فرص لآفاق
تطوير الأعمال والتوسع
المزيد ولا ينبغي أن تمتلكها الشركات الروسية
يفتقد
و البعض
الشركات التي غادرت سوف ترغب في العودة
الوضع فريد من نوعه دون مبالغة
للعديد من شركاتنا الحكومة
آمل أن
وتوقع العديد من المحللين الأجانب
نحن مكتئبون وفي ظل النزعة الاستهلاكية
وعدت القطاعات بأرضيات متاجر فارغة
النقص الهائل في فشل قطاع السلع
الخدمات ولكن الحياة مختلفة
أمرت ذلك بنفسك
الدول الغربية على مرأى ومسمع
واجهت نفس المشاكل
إلى الحد الذي يقترحه قادتهم
لمواطنيها بدلاً من الخس والطماطم
انتقل إلى اللفت اللفت منتج جيد ولكن
وربما سيتعين عليك القدوم إلينا لشراء اللفت أيضًا
اذهب لأن مستوى الحصاد لا يزال
لدينا
يتجاوز هذه الأرقام بشكل كبير
التي هي في جيراننا في
كان ينبغي لأوروبا أن تفعل شيئاً حسناً، لا شيء
والحقيقة هي أننا في هذا الاتجاه